the youngest candidate hard spoken for
campaign trail the clear front-runner so
start with the shoulder in a little my
name is Gary Hardin I'm running for
president I want you to think about the
opportunity that we have right here
right now
I've never known a guy more talented at
untangling politics so that anyone can
understand it is a gift and he wants to
share that along anybody wants is for
him to take the stupid photo you will
never understand that Gary Hart is the
man to beat in a day if we hold
ourselves to those highest standards in
the voters cannot do otherwise
senator want to ask you some questions
about the woman in your townhouse can
you tell us how you know her you can't
be serious no one is thing in my home
there's no need for that
[Music]
some one thing else does that you do
embarrass me you can't hide from this
the cameras go everywhere it's up to us
to hold these guys to come just because
some other paper use gossip bus front
page news I mean that doesn't mean we
have this does it does now
he is a man with power then that takes
certain responsibilities we need to say
something it's nobody's business none of
it is okay but we're not talking about
that you're talking about how you get
through today
this campaign is about the future not
rumors not sleaze and I care about the
sanctity of this process whether you do
or do not
[Music]
go on Gary say it there's gonna be a
story tomorrow about me
[Music]
you